I don't want to show you like a little
method that I use to work through these
proofs to make it a little bit easier
and give you a process so the first
thing I do is I look at the Givens and I
say to myself you know why are they
telling these given these are generally
clues or hints something that you can
figure out and then add it's a statement
in your proof so let's go to the Givens
here WY bisects segment X Z so WY let's
see here's WY bisects X Z so WY is
cutting X Z in half meaning that this
half is congruent to that half now when
I figure something out and you might
want to do this to is go ahead and mark
it on the diagram so you don't have to
remember it you can see it visually on
the diagram another thing that sometimes
students get confused by is they'll say
okay XR is congruent to Zr and they'll
also say WR is congruent to yr that's
only true if let's see if XZ is
bisecting WY but that's not what we have
here we have WY is the one that's doing
the cutting in half WY is cutting XZ in
half so XR is congruent to XC Z and
let's make that a step in our proof
segment XR is congruent to segment what
do we say Zr right Zr okay and that's
because of the definition of segment
bisector so I'm just reading a little
bit here now you notice I skipped number
1 step 1
generally what students like to do and I
like to do it too just to get it out of
the way is go ahead and write down the
Givens as your first step so you don't
have to do it that way sometimes it
makes the proof flow a little bit better
if you put some of the Givens you know
as you need them in the proof but a lot
of students just like to write them
first so I'll go ahead and do that here
so WY
bisects XZ and then we also have W X is
parallel to Z Y now why is this a hint
that W X is parallel to Z Y now I like
to draw an arrow if the two lines are
parallel the other thing I like to do is
I like to extend these lines a little
bit further and you can see that this is
like a transversal right here so I'm
going to extend that so what we have
here is we have a diagram
like what we learned earlier in geometry
two parallel lines cut by a transversal
and we know that the alternate interior
angles are congruent so in this diagram
what we can see here is is that this
angle let's just say right here is
congruent to the angle right there so
what I did is I use this transversal
notice that this angle has this
transversal as one of its sides and this
parallel line is one of its sides and
this angle has this common transversal
as one of its sides and this other
parallel line is one of its sides so
that's the key sometimes students
mistakenly would use these two angles or
they'll pick another set of two angles
but you want to make sure it's the
angles that are made up of that common
transversal and the two parallel lines
so again we might like to mark that on
the diagram I also like to make it as a
step in the proof when I figure
something out from the Givens so that
means that angle x wy angle X WI is
congruent to angle
let's see z YW z y w and that's by
alternate interior angle so i'm just
going to abbreviate okay now let's see
what we have so far we've got angles we
have some sides that are congruent it
looks like that's all we could figure
out from the Givens so the next thing I
like to do is jump into the diagram kind
of see if there's anything that I can
prove that's congruent in this diagram
keeping in mind that what we're trying
to prove is that triangle X WR that's
this triangle is congruent to triangle z
yr that's this triangle right here so
one thing you don't kind of watch out
for is like common sides you know if
they share a side that and that sides
gonna be congruent also you want to pay
attention to when you have this X
pattern the angles that are across from
each other are going to be congruent by
vertical angles and that's exactly what
we have here we have this angle let's go
to this angle because you see how that X
is formed those are vertical angles are
congruent so let's go ahead and add that
to our proof our two column proof here
we're going to say angle zr y z ry is
congruent to angle x our w x our w and
we said that's by vertical angle theorem
or if you say vertical angles now it
looks like we have enough to prove the
two triangles are congruent now using
the angle angle side angle angle side
now when you write your triangle
congruence
statement you want to make sure that the
corresponding vertices match up the
corresponding angles of corresponding
sides etc but what we're trying to prove
here that's always going to be your last
step in your proof so step number five
triangle X WR is congruent to triangle
zy r and that's going to be by an angle
angle side now one thing I want to just
show you over here to the side real
quick is see you have two triangles see
when you do angle angle side okay what
you want is you want to be able to go
around the triangle
you know either clockwise or
counterclockwise in order so it's like
angle the next angle you come to the
next side you don't want to jump around
like angle and like this side and the
same you know it has to go in that order
angle angle side that's very important
now it could be on this triangle here or
something like angle angle side so here
I'm going around counterclockwise but
you can see if I reflect this triangle
the sides going to match up the two
angles are going to match up and again
you're using the angle angle side so
great job I hope that helps you
understand how to work with triangle
congruence preusse a little bit better
I'll have a playlist right there that
you can check out having more experience
with working with these two column
proofs if you want to check that out go
ahead and do that subscribe to the
channel I look forward to seeing the
future videos I'll talk to you soon